[Music]
in peace out news
peace out peace up dude submitted by
Tycho Mary Leia no dudes and sisters
unless he gets horny
later on he goes I do want a [ __ ]
don't like go ahead that's pretty weird
know what that I guess no if they grew
up like hella hella hella close that's
really weird really or could be really
beautiful the mom says knows the way
doesn't know a dad who was reported
missing was found days later with his
new wife what do you [ __ ] sexist
bastards have to say about that Latino
justice all man
Tyko wait what happened I was thing
about Leia take a - what if we all
around the communes and you know the
parents because here's the thing and the
population of us imagine Tiger grows up
and he likes this girl because she's so
pretty but then you meet their parents
and you're like [ __ ] we gotta be in-laws
with these [ __ ] that's true within
and [ __ ] Christina's awesome people
with no class if the [ __ ] parents are
shitty we're probably shitty too but if
they're just pulling yourself
I want class in my [ __ ] world
and Jim are you ready for this here's my
sexist defense of this okay so this guy
his wife is [ __ ] crazy and she's not
very nice to him so he had to go mess up
a bad day he had to go missing to get
away from it but then he got another
wife why don't you ever go missing I'm
not crazy enough I ought to be crazy
because riding meetings aren't real
right [ __ ] I've seen him right there
writing he's crying for six hours about
how you make him say oh my [ __ ]
shoulder I need to bring towels like the
baby drool towel it's a criteria on a
tarp down - yeah
why do you come home so fast then that's
because mark I try to have your back
Steven he gave up in return dude his
name is Malcolm X in the middle he's 38
years old he is from Scotland school and
he ran away to Utah Utah
Scotland to Utah no way was it you - or
huh anyway in the u.s. you touch me
I always get those two confused Scotland
Cousineau Utah in Ohio I don't know why
Utah's Mormon country
Utah's like 85% Mormonism it is Utah
actually so he's been with this partner
for 27 years there were childhood
sweethearts
Manteca no they were never married but
he disappeared cuz he said that he was
gonna be visiting some family and he
didn't end up coming home so the partner
ended up reporting a missing there were
police looking for him everywhere and
somehow they found him in the u.s.
married that's amazing married yeah now
he married some lady over there so what
he was never married of the original
check no big [ __ ] deal that yeah so
he never he never gave her the ultimate
commitment kids together and you
probably just ever together for 27 years
duck people that's a lot these kids with
her I don't know how the kids are so he
just came into the u.s. had a know where
to marry someone and then did he meet
him online it turned out that they met
online and that she liked the wife a new
wife she went to Scotland at one point
because there somehow found like
Facebook messages and so he was cheating
she wanted to play them back yeah this
is Malcolm and Sheryl
who's Sheryl aren't the old partner yeah
this is that her nipple that way is
blurred nice just a great hold out titty
that's what it is what an unfortunate it
was a flash on her titty I think it's
one of those shiny photos and they took
a photo of the photo good investigation
skills to log on to yes this is a couple
when they first started dating 27 years
ago clothes TIFF [ __ ] solved it that
was deduced by 10 and then compliment
how many years that was complimenting oh
my god now and then this is him with his
new wife I thought his other girlfriend
was cuter or did time-pass do the things
not just about looks Joseph maybe this
one actually gives blood go back to the
one with him in his wife filters Ryan
yeah yeah little [ __ ]
wedeck's I was like I don't know when
they not renewable qualities other than
she must give bomb-ass [ __ ] me too
but she didn't
yeah that's true yeah I was hoping it
would be McDonald you wouldn't look like
AHA oh yeah that's it that's all this
story the whole story that I have for
you guys what happens when we don't
interrupt you we get a five-minute video
exactly song see so much thanks for
watching for watching we'll see you wait
wait no wait I think we can keep it
going
TIFF are you a little bit thankful that
we interrupt you so much so that we can
have produce longer video yeah I'm very
thankful I love it it's my favorite
thing of so you're sure are you gonna
thank us individually just did thank you
Steve
thank you Joe thank you Joe the most is
you a drop me be multi might be personal
personal thank yous cuz if you just say
gift card
no personal was yeah he wants to dragged
I don't know I made a big bar no make it
personal goal weight just it okay thank
Bart Thank You Steven what's the
personal one stop Tiffany you just
interrupted her thank you should they
apologize to your [ __ ] out all the
time I gotta take whatever they throw at
me I can finally speak in this video to
speak but not to these [ __ ] animals
you're so savvy you interrupting all
how's your day going though it's going
great I like your tie or a dress for the
wedding no I still didn't I have to
still find something for those of you
who are like oh I wish they wouldn't
stop interrupting tip this is what
freaking happens another time my wedding
dress
look how boring the video is I haven't
talked in the last two minutes the life
of the video disappears when I don't
interrupt if it has to be done what are
you wearing attends wedding I don't have
a dress we were just talking about if
you listen there the views are backed up
now every mistake you about Tiffany
naked you're welcome oh there you go
that's pretty good the bees are coming
back all right we were gonna rub oil on
her body oh that's pretty good yeah yeah
you get a little healthier they smell
amazing
no one's gonna do what are you gonna do
oil yep its new way to desexualize it
yeah let's go back to my other that's
not the good fat I got it
TIFF and you guys I got to desexualize
it I get it what I'm not here okay
you all are mothers two years ago well
your mother's now Tim's right oh hell
yeah not for long you know I mean not
for long and I mean yeah it's a really
short dress area yeah all this shoulder
all its chest what are you wearing the
pink one I don't know yet oh you guys
are texting each other last night yeah
we were looking it was like it was like
we were about to go to sleep right we're
about to go sleep about to shut it down
and I'm like brushing my teeth I'm
getting tired and I keep seeing her like
take a dress out take a picture
put that away I'm like we just agreed
we're gonna go to sleep why are you
agreed you gonna go
it's Indians treaties just [ __ ] knock
out why don't you my [ __ ] opinion her
to be a bad with you yeah welcome to
this [ __ ] night we agreed when your
great to go to sleep there's a tractor
you wake up in the middle of night and
you're getting a snack he's like we
didn't agree to this
he's like you cause [ __ ] a [ __ ]
one I bet you're part going to sleep and
five minutes later he wakes up and he
goes no agreement NGOs all awake like on
her fault like what go to sleep
and she's not there I go to see my arms
crossed like this and I looked my check
every five minutes you're frowning yeah
you're frowning face I got two babies I
used to do when Steve would go home at
5:00 in the morning cuz he'd be riding
all day and there was no service where
he would write but he was telling me he
was gonna come home to have sex but he
wouldn't I'd be waiting up and I'd be
like this and then finally I just got a
bit like this you kept there waiting for
that day well you know it is the time
gets away from you when you're writing
[ __ ] it just does it does just text
would be nice I'm not coming home yeah
but I have a no phones rule I don't even
look at my phone that's that's really
hard to do like time just goes by like
that you feel like 30 minutes went and
it was like three hours
yaar seven yeah so sudden alarm that's
not bad yeah well you know a lot of
think I had about certain things yeah
they're not selfish I usually put in
airplane mode as well but I can still
sell more it doesn't happen anymore so
that's okay that's true I come home now
yeah I get you I get you laid I got him
all needy how did you do that I don't
know he changed I had some success and I
didn't feel like I had to suffer anymore
changed is that you guys have different
hours for your writing because someone
wants to get home to their kids so now
he doesn't go as long as he used to to
get it done to a favor
my man did your face me a favor
I'm feeling way more like you like you
like him riding with us more than his
other riding buddy I don't care anymore
cuz I got used to the other way so if
you guys like when you went on the
weekend retreat to write the first movie
when you have no dick for four days yeah
oh please I'm [ __ ] loud mean and it
smells nice yeah right after the first
day you're like oh it's not first day
[ __ ] hour okay I know but you're
gonna act like it's just been like hey
squids advice cool right now
she's like just stylin right now so I'll
like you she likes it what I don't like
it that's true that's the true she ever
so at least it works oh yeah [ __ ]
broom you [ __ ] pervert and you just
do where talk about blow apart like five
minutes ago I am a pervert yeah he had
and then he took it away but front by
himself that's true same video I like
what why does that that was like a 90%
off the record video yeah he killed it
dog it was funny game though
[Music]